a different way to workout and a really
different way to think about my body and
it was very empowering lady wrestling I
get it women can do anything then do
blah blah blah
Alison Brie made it a date night with
husband de Franco at the premiere of her
new Netflix series glow gorgeous ladies
of wrestling a comedy drama about female
wrestlers in the 80s well it was so fun
to train for this show because it was
all about strength it was fun to be able
to think of myself as an athlete first
and an actor second it was about
building muscle not about getting skinny
doing tons of cardio not only did all
that training come in handy on set
Alison joked it's helped at home with
Dave too
I put him in a headlock when you know he
does the wrong thing no and when it
comes to doing nude scenes the actress
said she's alerted a few key people
ahead of time I've warned my dad at
length but many of them reminded him
again and then sort of given him a
heads-up of like exact people on like so
when you see this person you know what's
about to happen maybe fast forward I
feel like oh you know Dave Steve's a
tough guy
[Applause]
[Music]
you